James first of all let's start with the
challenges for the students what are we
seeing yeah I mean I think it's really
tough we ran really unprecedent of time
right now kids and and really it's not
just the kids the families the parents
they're having to adjust to learning
online and but you know I think there's
a there's a silver lining to a lot of
this and the silver lining hopefully
that people see is that a lot of
families a lot of parents they can spend
more time with their kids get involved
their education I think it's a real
opportunity for parents and kids to
connect what about parents of special
education students you know one of my
neighbors is dealing with some
challenges right now because her little
one doesn't do well with the digital
learning it's it's hard and you know and
the reality is is that online or digital
learning it's not for everybody in
special education kids you know they do
they have some special needs that
sometimes you can't really address
appropriately in an online learning
environment so right now I think a lot
of school districts are trying to deal
with how do they how do they handle
those situations and I don't think I
don't think we've really worked through
that yet online learning can work very
effectively for some special education
situations but certainly not for all so
I think we have to take the guidelines
of the home districts as well and see
what they want to do and how they want
to address it you know James I'm curious
about the psychological component for
little ones when they're you know we
tell them it's only gonna be for a
period of time but when you see what
Kansas did for K through 12 for the rest
of the academic year sure and and some
talk of the word indefinite I've had to
teach my ten-year-old really what that
means that has an impact what what is it
well listen we're living in a different
world it's it's gonna impact all of us
psychologically in some way shape or
form I think a lot of us are getting
cabin fever just by not being able to go
into the office as well I think for kids
specifically they need structure and in
order for them to get through their day
they need to have a set of structures so
I think I really encourage parents to
set up a structure of this that's what
the schools do they have first period
then they go to second period then
recess or whatever giving kids that
sense of structure I think is really
important but also taking advantage of
the tools that are available out there
k12 we've got a bunch of online tools
and resources that people can use to
help
in this situation we're going to be
rolling out some free online resources
here in the next week reading tools you
know so I think really the most
important thing is to provide that
structure and use the resources that are
available to parents